[Music]
okay
got done seeing Aquaman and I'm gonna
start off by saying that DC's got a hit
on on its hands this is a really good
movie I liked it didn't you
it was it was like you know what I
thought it was kind of cool about it one
that imagery is amazing yeah that's
really cool in the title role I also
thought like I thought it was cool that
they kind of went with the inherent
cheesiness of the premise yeah and made
it on the news right yeah just brought
what they what they do it's fun it's
cheesy but it's fun cheesy yeah and it's
kind of like it's weird it gets
extremely epic it gets to a point where
the scale just gets bigger and bigger
and bigger the creatures are so big
they're Godzilla level yeah all right
and it's happening underneath the water
and they're flying through it and it's
on technology and they're riding sharks
and submarines that yeah armored sea
horses and and everything's like ship
yeah ships that look like them what do
you call them Portuguese MANOWAR's what
you have is you have basically kind of
like the story of Superman and it's
taking place in a Flash Gordon style
world
it was very flash because under the sea
is kind of like space and the Atlanteans
have a lot of technology he also took a
lot of ideas from Conan yeah of course
Momoa played Conan and in one scene in
this movie he takes a trident from a
dead Atlantean king and that King passes
it on to him he's got the magic tried it
well that's right out of Conan the
Barbarian where Conan takes this goes
into a tomb of an Atlantean King and
takes his sword so there's a there they
did a lot of good like epic callbacks to
other great movies and the movies kind
of serving kind of like a Star Wars
movie
I thought when the Star Wars movie in a
splash Gordon movie over the splash
court I already want to see the sequel
because they set up a sequel already to
got a sequel because we use super
villain yeah and the way that they've
laid out this particular story there is
a lot of potential because what's under
you know that undersea is a vast region
so a lot of [ __ ] could happen as they
develop that particular series now on
the back of this I really would like to
see Jason Momoa into a reboot of Conan a
good one he would be yeah it wasn't his
problem he was Conan he played Conan I
believe meant in that reboot I think
that was him I didn't see the problem
with that one was the script I didn't
really like it but with what's possible
today you could actually reboot that and
get a much better company yeah and I'd
also like to see on the back of this I'd
like her to see him do the Dino De
Laurentiis style Flash Gordon yeah
imagine if they did with today's
technology that old Flash Gordon and I
would like him to be almost kind of like
r-rated yeah or really heavy PG because
because you're that the that one Flash
Gordon had a lot of sexual undertones to
it and so did the original Flash Gordon
series over town yeah and the original
was like that that was cheering the
source material but yeah good movie no
storytelling was good there are certain
times where it gets so epic and the
almost kind of becomes a little too much
like yeah it's like like I said it's an
inherently ridiculous premise it's a you
know Atlanta is real that it is real
there's like seven and they have like
vastly superior technology to the
surface world government to keep this
secret right and all this other kind of
stuff so like I said it seemed kind of
cool that they just decided we're just
yeah it was like a mystic ridiculously
like epic action it I thought it worked
yeah
I think it worked because Jason Momoa
playing Aquaman is a very down-to-earth
character I mean he's on the surface
world he doesn't want to go back to
Atlantis and be king and so he's kind of
like a schlubby you know he's just kind
of do that big is not slow you know well
he was still kind of a man of the sea in
a way just wanted to be immortal so I
think he was kind of like the thing that
I heard and made it seem not so but like
I said they obviously did this on did
that on purpose and I think it actually
worked I think it was like pretty
entertaining for the most part I just
don't like superhero movies I don't
really like a moun either I just think
it's over there all right but this this
one I think that has a lot of potential
because yeah this one is a good one and
with this you could do what Star Wars
does you could do what Flash Gordon does
you could you could make five of these
movies probably make a lot of money
yeah the transfer monster people they
said that was the coolest part to make
as you know I love scary [ __ ] so it's
like I really liked that part where they
had to go with the trench and they're
all the creatures yeah they just set it
up on the boat they just set up a good
universe you could make an entire series
on this the same way star wars did yeah
because there's like I said there's
seven kingdoms they only really had a
couple of scenes yeah they just kind of
laid it out that there's a lot of [ __ ]
down yeah and that they have to go and
there's like all these alliances between
that one so yeah there's a lot of places
they could go with this and I guess if
it's a hit they probably this is gonna
be a hit this I can't see how this is
not gonna be yeah I can't see how this
was a very crowd I think they I think DC
knocked it out of the park with this one
as long as they make the sequel good
than they're they'll do good job yeah
okay just got done from seeing the
favorite which is a period piece court
intrigue place in the 1700s if it's
about kind of a court of Queen and I
don't know if this is actually the
historical Queen Anne or not I have no
idea how historical this was but the the
acting was good and the sets are really
cool it takes place in a real palace
yeah costumes look good and everything
like that very much long lines I was
surprised se reminded me a lot of
dangerous lady I was just gonna say yeah
I feel like dangerous yeah kind of like
a touch of Amadeus yeah yeah one of the
things that they never was noticed about
kind of stereotypical concepts of the 17
in the eighteen hundred's it was always
kind of showed us a kind of a prudish
past and serf MTO says no because I saw
the chain and they were all chained in
this movie that's about two women trying
to two women trying to get as much
leverage and influence over the Queen as
possible and just everything was on the
table including like seduction and all
kinds of weird [ __ ] so but you know one
of the one of the women in the
industries was a noblewoman that lost
all of her land and her power and she
ends up being employed in the in the
palace and tries to work her way up
through the ranks with the means and
woman has it or hand on hand and of
course there are other women trying to
stop or and you know the men and
everything
like about the movie is the kind of show
that kind of a showed that you know how
much power women actually had in those
old ports yeah and it probably goes all
way back to ancient Egypt on ancient
Greece about how much power when rich
women actually had in those courts
because they're smart and wily yeah they
had a lot of leverage over the men -
yeah you know I could recommend a movie
I think that the ending was a little
weak I thought but oh yeah what other
than that you know I enjoy it what you
think I didn't do I really I really
really liked it a lot like I mean
Dangerous Liaisons in its many
iterations like I read the play and you
know and I've seen like a bunch of
different versions of it and that's
probably one of my favorite movies ever
and if you and Amadeus is also one of my
favorite movies ever so if you like
those two movies I would really
recommend this one it's actually it's
very like other than being like really
beautiful and like the acting is really
amazing it's actually really funny like
all of the you know because all the
court like all the quips they make with
one another that's all this like barn
wit and everything very very very yeah
very gritty yeah you know what I mean
but honestly I think that's probably
more historically accurate than ones
that are have yeah everybody all proper
yeah no they were they were bad yes just
we have decide that was from that time
yeah yeah yeah and like kind of tried to
you know like said trying to almost try
to take advantage of the Queen but then
it turns out she's probably not so
easily taken
and each other I think she was going on
the whole time she had some problems
yeah I wouldn't probably call her crazy
but she wasn't in the greatest mental
health so yeah anyway like I said I have
no idea how historical this was it
probably not historical but it was a
good story it was a really good story
and like I said if you dig Dangerous
Liaisons you definitely take this it's
for actually really really funny really
really good I really enjoyed it very
much
yeah yeah all right
[Music]
all right we just got done seen what was
it called homes right Holmes Holmes and
Watson yeah what are the name of these
guys that did this it's john c reilly
and will ferrell yeah it's it's the zany
comedy i liked the first half of it and
then it kind of it took a weird turn in
the story where holmes starts accusing
watson of being the main suspect yeah
and it kind of threw me out of it it
started to get kind of negative the way
it was and the very like the first
two-thirds of the movie I really like to
edit
I like the what'd he call it like the
tone yeah then they came in with that
kind of that weird twist yeah where they
threw him in the prison then it goes
into almost a romantic musical first you
see it is that [ __ ] threw me out of
it and then they hit you with like three
or four real like negative just negative
political messages about unfair pay and
guns and electoral college [ __ ] and I
was like man it's just too contemporary
and then it tries to recover and kind of
get that same tone that it had in the in
the first two-thirds but I never really
could get back into it the humor all
kind of to feel sour and back to me
after that yeah that's just it was
almost kind of like it was made by two
different people like somebody did the
first two-thirds and somebody else
finished it off and then they just ended
the movie it didn't have a uniform tone
yeah and it wasn't just me I listen to
the audience the audience was thrown out
of it too
a lot of them they stopped laughing yeah
I think yeah I think like the funny I
mean funny stuff was on the food juicer
stepbrothers and Talladega Nights this
is the same type of humor you know it's
like dumb like slaps yeah that's some
funny [ __ ] there was like some funny
like references I thought the first two
days yeah there is the first the first
half from first year it was pretty funny
but yeah it was still kind of funny at
the end it's almost like somebody
stepped in and said let me finish this
movie yeah and it's kind of just cobble
to finish together and it was like look
we have all these little paid
advertisements that we had to do and so
let's just talk about this we have to
talk about this and didn't let's just
wrap up the movie it it really it felt
like it was it felt like it was made by
two different people yeah but I liked
that first two-thirds of it I thought it
was thoughtless [ __ ] funny but the
rest of it is just kind of like kind of
overstayed his welcome as soon as it
went into the musical thing I was like
and I'm doing this now and then I
noticed that like all the steam got
pulled out of the audience people
stopped laughing and it was like yeah it
stops yeah and then I should say that
it's like like I said I don't read
reviews of stuff where I'm gonna see
them but when I'm you know going and
like making the you know reservation for
the movie sometimes I'll see like
headlines about it and this is getting
like terrible terrible review this like
most who's saying just like it's just
not funny it's just not but like I said
the first part of it was funny I think
maybe that's what people are talking
about that like maybe it has like a lot
of funny parts at the beginning and then
just that that mystical number when it
went negative like that it just sucked
all the energy out
yeah to me I was like this is not a
friendly movie like I said that could
have been done well but I don't think
they pulled it off completely right yeah
it was a bad edit and some bad decisions
they should have kept it just
light-hearted fun to the whole thing
like a buddy pitcher and to have them
turn on him have him turn on him like
that it just made the movie
mean-spirited I I felt was like wait a
minute he's turned on his buddy yeah and
I like oh come on you know what I mean
and then like I said it when then those
rapid succession of negative messages
came at you because I think the whole
point of the character of you know Will
Ferrell Sherlock Holmes is that he's an
idiot who thinks he's like really smart
so I mean obviously yeah that's him was
not the killer but it's like the fact
that he thought he wasn't he was thought
yeah probably a genius for figuring that
out so I can see how they could they
could have done that well but I just I
don't know they didn't do it I think it
is I just I just don't like to
overanalyze things in terms of like try
to over rationalize what happened was is
that it was a funny movie then off then
there was a rapid succession of negative
messages boom boom boom boom boom and
she held the movie yeah that's all it
was
yeah it's like they turned on each other
he goes to prison alright [ __ ] women
aren't paid as much there's guns in
America the left go ecology yeah this is
a dictatorship there's just way to hold
a home away and it happened within like
a four-minute period yeah and then the
movie couldn't recover after that
because it it sucked the fun it's a
positive movie yeah you know so they
through negative humor in there and it
just it couldn't recover yeah that's
what I think happen but other than that
man I just don't know who it felt like
it was directed by two different people
yeah it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't a
total loss though then at first
two-thirds of it was on yes a free fun
movie it was funny it reminded me
that mr. bean was oh yeah kind of the
same yeah and then it cut its nuts off
yeah everything that was good about it
it just erased it yeah
[Music]